VAAKANAINEN'S BACKHANDER TRIED
TO SNEAK IT FIVE-HOLE ON
OETTINGER WHO COVERS UP.
>> OETTINGER, BUT LOOK AT
HOW TIGHTLY THOSE KNEES WER OF T
CORNER THAT HAS AGAIN.
SENDS IT AROUND.
LINDELL GOT IT TO THE CARRICK OT
PRESSING HIGH ON THE PENALTY
KILL
FAKSA FINDS THE BACK OF THE NET!
VAAKANAINEN TRYING TO PUT THE I.
MAYHEW COMES UP WITH ONE AND
HERE IS PETERSON ANOTHER O
THAT.. TAKEN BY ASTON-REESE WHO
GOES AFTER THE REBOUND BUT
OETTINGER COVERS RIGHT BACK IN T
AND BRAD GETS A BOUNCE TO TIE
THE G
I THINK IT'S LINDELL.
I THINK IT'S OFF LINDELL AND
THEN THE GOALTENDER OETTINGER
AND INTO THE BACAC FEELING THROE
BUBBLE PLAYOFFS.
TERRY GETS ITOINT.
HEISKANEN LOOKING FOR A TIP.
ENDS UP IN THE SLOT.
GOOD KICK
LOOKED LIKE OETTINGER HAD ONE, H
INTO THE PUCK.
THAT MAY HAVEE
LIVELY REBOUND IS ZEGRAS.
OFF THE GLOVE OF OETTINGER.
ZONE.FROM LETTIERI.
DRYSDALE SPUN AROUND GLENDENINGE
VERY END, WHAT A STOP BY J J IND
BY PAVELSKI.
SENDS IT ACROSS.T RIGHT
HERE.
YEAH, IT'S OFF THE RIGHTAS
DRYSDALE BROUGHT BACK BY JAMIE
BENN INTO THE MIDDLE. DOWN BY L.
CARRICK ALL FOLLOWS UP AND
OETTINGER, WATCH HOW HE GETS HIS
SHOULDERS HIGH.
IT'S EASY IT D
MAYHEW AND GETZLAF.
GETZLAF TAKES THE SHOT.
IT'S SMOTHERER PUCK CARRIER.
YOU CAN SEE HE WANTED TO GIVIV E
NET.
TRYING TO STUFF IT IS ROBERTSON.
LOOSE AT THE SIDE OF THE NET.
KNKN
LEFT PAD SAVE BY GIBSONVATE IT,E
STARS HAVE DRAWN EVEN HINTZ
WAS RIGHT IN THE SLOTIGHT OFF TF
R
JACOB P PETERSON SPENT FOUR
YEARS IN THE SWEDISH ELITE
LEAGUE AFTER BEING A NEUTRAL ZO.
DRYSDALE RETREATING.
PAVELSKI TAKES IT BACK.
GOT IT IN FRONT.
GLENDENING WINS THE FACE-OFF.
HE WAS SECOND BEST IN THE LEAGUE
A YEAR AGO.
DIDN'T WASTE ANY TIME.
HE